[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission ou
par l'alimentation agriculture cuisine
mais aussi politique et cette semaine
nous recevons Audrey Pulvar et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte bonjour Audrey
bonjour Brigitte boucher bonjour Audrey
vous êtes adjointe d'Annie dalgo à la
mairie de Paris chargée de
l'alimentation durable de l'agriculture
et des circuits courts on est loin du
milieu très paillettes des médias un
petit peu moins authentiques où vous
avez évolué pendant plusieurs années au
Soir 3 à RTL i-Télé ou encore aux côtés
de Laurent Ruquier dans On n'est pas
couché c'était sur France 2 rien ne
laissait présager une telle volte-face
sauf que l'engagement a toujours fait
plus ou moins partie de votre vie
journaliste militante politique engagé
mais pour quelle cause on aurait pu on
aurait dû mettre alerté quand vous avez
posé pour Paris Match avec une botte de
foin à votre fourche
mais oui bien sûr celle de vos origines
celle dont vous êtes native la
Martinique et c'est là-bas à 6845 km de
Paris que vous nous emmenez pour ce
déjeuner n'est-ce pas Jean-Pierre donc
tout en restant à Paris ce sont des
accras centraces carbone mais avec de la
morue et un court bouillon au poisson et
en dessert on change le registre une
religieux au chocolat ah oui dans le
dessous des plats le bio ne fait plus
recette les consommateurs sans
détournent au profit du local dans les
pieds dans le plat à quoi ressemble ces
fermes du futur qui incarne
l'agriculture de demain reportage
Amsterdam à suivre allez on passe à
table tout de suite cuisine et
confidence
Audrey Pulvar pour vous avoir concocté
pendant quatre saisons à la télé en tant
que cuistot de ces dames des petits
plats qui suscitaient chez vous pas tous
les coups je le reconnais un intérêt
certain voir parfois une sorte de
contentement et de satisfaction je sais
que chez vous existe un amour pour la
bonne bouffe qu'elle soit gastro étoilée
bistro voire même en bons produits
incollables aussi sur les plats totems
de la cuisine traditionnelle de
métropole vous développez une sincère
curiosité pour les cuisines du monde
méditerranéenne asiatiques africaines
indienne rien ne vous rebute au
contraire vous avez toujours le palais
en alerte impatiente de connaître de
nouveaux goûts et de nouvelles
expériences mais malgré tout ça je
savais qu'ici face à nous avec Brigitte
le seul plat qui compte et celui que
vous aviez envie de nous faire découvrir
et celui qui vous permet de retrouver
vos racines antillaises histoire de nous
montrer votre appétit profond pour les
trésors gustatifs de vos îles donc faute
d'avoir trouvé un restaurateur capable
de préparer des recettes très locales
vous nous offrez du glace du classique
avec des accras de morue et un cours
bouillon de poisson et dites-nous s'il
vous plaît en créole que l'on va se
régaler en créole
la langue je peux vous le dire mais
c'est ouais nous question c'est doit
être voilà
il y a plein de possibilités en fait et
en le disant je reprends un peu l'accent
martiniquais vous avez vu il y a plein
de possibilités c'est une langue qui est
très très imagée
un mot créole mais qui est rentré dans
le langage commun le court-bouillon on
connaît en France mais je ne sais pas si
un court bouillon français est préparé
comme un congélateur Brigitte m'a dit on
va avoir du corbouillon parce que Audrey
veut ça je m'attendais à quelque chose
de beaucoup plus liquide etc c'est un
bouillon de maths en fait typique on
mangeait un peu tous les jours c'est pas
un plat de fête par exemple chez vous
c'est tous les jours peut-être pas parce
que le poisson alors il faut que ce soit
par exemple du vivano etc le poisson
reste quand même cher mais c'est pas non
plus un plat de fête on va dire c'est un
plat de repas de famille le dimanche
quoi moi je pense qu'il faut manger les
accras parce que oui il faut s'asseoir
c'est le plateau le plus difficile que
j'ai jamais fait de ma vie parce que là
il faut parler et manger en même temps
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué on va
juste vous demander de goûter en général
je fais semblant à de manger à la télé
mais là je suis vraiment obligé de
manger heureusement ma mère m'a bien
élevé et donc à priori alors il y a de
la science mais méfiez-vous hein
piquant il y a un petit piment alors ce
piment là il m'a l'air plutôt
réunionnais comme martiniquais ouais
mais il est très
forticas créole qui est rue Dido dans le
14e et qui nous a préparé c'est c'est
bon petit plats ils sont très bon et moi
si ça vous intéresse alors bien sûr que
ça nous intéresse
alors c'est vrai que le dire devant
trois choses à savoir pour bien réussir
ses accras devant on aurait pu le voir
alors de bons accras doivent être à la
fois légers bien garnis et croustillant
c'est un peu le cas croustillant c'est
pas la faute du restaurateur mais il
faut rappeler qu'ils ont été réchauffés
au micro donc qui perdent un peu de leur
de leur croustillant pour la garniture
outre la chair de morue si on fait des
accras à la morue jouer bien sur les
condiments à épiments échalote épices
pour rendre vos accras plus légères j'ai
une astuce vous ajoutez une bonne pincée
de levure ou du bicarbonate de soude ça
les rendra un peu plus légers et vous
rajoutez la farine et l'eau à la fin de
la pâte et cette pâte ne doit être ni
trop liquide ni trop compact alors voilà
pas trop de farine 2 attention
maintenant à la cuisson choisir une
huile neutre pas d'huile d'olive par
exemple qui n'existe pas en Martinique
plutôt une huile d'arachide tournesol ou
mixte la température idéale c'est 170
degrés parce qu'au-delà 180 ça les brûle
ça et en dessous
et ne cuisent pas au cœur donc voilà
donc c'est plutôt 170 160 ça n'ira pas
180 ça n'ira pas et encore
de la nourriture
et enfin pour confectionner vos acrasses
ou servir de deux petites cuillères
parce que là il y a un geste une pour
saisir la petite boule de pâte et
l'autre pour la faire glisser dans
l'huile et là il y a un petit geste sec
et précis à donner et il faut toujours
déguster les accras encore chaud et
croustillant et enfin si vous reste de
la pâte ne faites pas des accras pour
les congeler congelez plutôt la pâte
c'est une meilleure idée absolument vous
êtes d'accord avec tout ce qui vient
d'être parfait vous vous avez les
préparer oui mais je laisse je laisse ça
à ma maman
quand je vais en Martinique je me fais
vraiment chouchouter par ma maman donc
je sais faire je sais faire la cuisine
quand je suis ici
en France métropolitaine à Paris je fais
plutôt de la cuisine française puisque
j'utilise plutôt des produits locaux de
saison mais oui je sais faire les accras
et quand c'est Maman qui les fait c'est
mieux non mais pas que de la morue on
peut faire des
accras alors le
est-ce que j'ai le temps de vous
expliquer allez-y pour pouvoir pour
votre édification pour vos dîner en
ville en fait au départ là ce qu'on
appelle Acra c'est des marinades en fait
on appelle ça des marinades donc la pâte
sans la morue juste là la base de la
pâte on peut la faire on peut faire sans
morue et ce qu'on fait par exemple le
vendredi saint vendredi saint samedi
Gloria dimanche de Pâques lundi de
Pâques et le plat typique c'est les
accras donc sans morue ou avec du chou
etc après quand on rajoute la morue ce
ne sont plus des marinades ce sont des
accras de morue mais on peut aussi
mettre des crevettes on peut aussi
mettre du lambi je sais pas si vous
savez
qui qui ouvre refuge dans un coquillage
mais on mange pas le coquillage on mange
le mollusque on peut en faire à plein de
choses en fait c'est plutôt des on en
fait plutôt avec des produits de la mer
n'est pas enfin moi je connais pas dacra
de viande mais bon la base c'est la
marinade et ensuite les accras de morue
comme maintenant on décline
c'est important et vous aimez vous aimez
cuisiner vous prenez mais vous avez le
temps de le faire ou vous le prenez en
tout cas oui le temps de le weekend à ce
moment-là j'adore ça alors j'ai beaucoup
cuisiner pour ma fille et maintenant
elle est elle est grande elle n'habitue
chez moi mais donc je cuisine pour mes
amis je cuisine pour moi-même parfois je
me fais un petit plaisir je me fais un
bon plat et quoi vos plats signatures si
on pouvait dire alors le bas en croûte
de sel
grand classique en fait moi je suis pas
super forte en cuisine par contre je
mets beaucoup de soins avoir des bons
produits et je pense que une fois qu'on
a les bons produits il faut il faut
maîtriser le produit et la cuisson ça
c'est la le secret ce que j'allais dire
parce que le bar en croûte de sel c'est
pas évident on le voit pas le poisson on
peut pas du tout
je trouve que quand même c'est moins bon
c'est sûr mais je trouve que quand même
quand on a l'habitude rien que l'odeur
alors elle est très couvert par la
croûte de sel mais rien que à l'odeur on
sait si la cuisson est bonne ou pas
l'odeur qui se répand dans la maison et
puis non sinon je fais je fais pas mal
de soupes des potages qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait là j'avais un dîner récemment avec
des amis je leur ai fait un en fait je
fais en fonction de ce que je trouve
j'ai trouvé des châtaignes je me suis
dit je vais en faire un velouté de
châtaignes j'ai fait un velouté de
châtaignes j'ai fait des talets à
tagliatelles fraîche aux cèpes ou
shiitake parce que c'est ce que j'avais
donc c'est quand même les produits
je n'arrive pas à être bonne en
pâtisserie parce que c'est trop précis
ah oui oui impossible la recette à la
lettre
à côté c'est le grammage parfait même
lorsqu'on avait fait de la télé ensemble
il y avait un grand pâtissier qui était
venu mais c'était trop pris sur les
grammages et ça avait été une
catastrophe et dans votre répertoire de
cuisine c'est quoi le mixte antillais
France métropole l'iten alors les épices
les épices
antillais et puis en général parce que
ça peut être là c'est du je pense que
c'est un piment réunionnais mais si j'en
trouve je serais contente d'en trouver
et puis c'est la distance c'est une
bonne résistance à l'épices parce que là
il faut faire attention
la cannelle la muscade la vanille des
choses comme ça qui viennent qui
viennent de nos outre-mer évidemment et
puis et puis sinon c'est de temps en
temps aller faire le marché à
Ménilmontant ou dans des endroits comme
ça pour trouver à Belleville les bonnes
boutiques et les bons produits alors
pour revenir et parler un peu des
Antilles parce que nous ça nous fait
rêver un peu ils sont très bons les
accord
dans les plats et il y avait d'autres
plats qui étaient proposés alors Tiné de
morue je crois que je sais pas comment
on dit
c'est le plat de base vraiment c'est un
plat de de tous les jours quoi des
familles les familles modestes ou c'est
assez simple c'est des bananes vertes
qui sont encore vertes en fait elles
sont mûres à l'intérieur mais la peau
est verte c'est pas des bananes
complémentées comme un dessert c'est
vraiment des bananes qu'il faut faire
cuire
c'est un petit goût sucré mais il faut
les faire cuire on peut pas les manger
comme ça donc c'est des bananes vertes
très dur à trouver en France
en Asie et de la morue alors de la morue
séchée qu'on fait des salés et qu'on
prépare avec un peu d'huile d'olive
enfin d'huile de tournesol ou d'arachide
et puis des des aromates et tout ça
c'est vraiment un plat basique basique
je faisais la comparaison c'est le petit
salé aux lentilles des ouvriers voilà
c'est vraiment plat basique et le
kalalou alors ça c'est un vraiment un
régal mais c'est aussi un plat familial
assez simple c'est une soupe de d'herbe
en fait c'est une soupe verte avec toute
sorte d'herbes avec des gombos avec ça
c'est vraiment très très bon dans tous
les plats que vous avez cités c'est
généralement du poisson alors c'est vrai
que les îles sont vraiment tournés vers
la mer
végétarienne ou vous faites attention à
manger moins de viande je dirais que je
suis on va dire aux trois quarts
végétariennes et un peu donc un peu
flexitarienne en fait parce qu'il
m'arrive encore alors je suis pas du
tout végétalienne parce que je n'ai
absolument aucun moyen de me passer de
fromage de beurre et de
surtout le fromage mais
la viande mais on s'en était déjà parlé
à l'époque où on travaille ensemble
Jean-Pierre il y a longtemps déjà moi ça
fait
peut-être 20 ans je n'ai pas arrêté la
viande mais j'en consomme beaucoup moins
et de meilleure qualité pour une
question de
climat alors à l'époque pour la question
du bien-être animal pour une question de
santé pour une question de préservation
de l'environnement parce qu'on sait que
le régime carnet a un impact extrêmement
fort sur sur l'environnement le régime
végétarien
est celui qui est le moins dommageable
pour l'environnement j'ai beaucoup de
réserves bon je vais peut-être me faire
des ennemis mais j'ai beaucoup de
réserves sur le régime vegan parce que
certes on préserve le bien-être animal
c'est sûr en revanche les exhausteurs de
goût
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on y gagne en
termes de santé publique et des missions
de gaz à effet de serre et en termes
d'équilibre calorique
en termes d'équilibre calorique alors
sur le fer on entend dans les
légumineuses
on les trouve on les trouve ailleurs on
n'est pas on n'a pas les eaux fragiles
si on est végétarien le régime
végétalien peut-être un peu plus carencé
et puis sur le véganisme moi je suis pas
contre le principe je dis juste voilà
qu'est-ce qui substitue et dans quelles
conditions sont produits les aliments de
substitution je j'ai quelques doutes
pour les avoir vu dans les supermarchés
dans les épiceries bio etc je trouve
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup d'additifs
beaucoup d'exhausteurs beaucoup de sucre
parfois beaucoup de sel et je pense que
voilà pour moi rien ne rien ne vaut un
brocoli vapeur avec son petit filet
d'huile d'olive c'est
Jean-Pierre disait vous êtes une bonne
mangeuse vous êtes Gourmande
vous savez je suis française
et en France je n'ai pas souvent été
d'accord avec Nicolas Sarkozy j'ai
plutôt été en désaccord avec lui et je
le demeure mais j'a que inscrire le
repas français au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO c'était une très belle idée et
que et que elle ait pu être réalisée je
trouve que c'est ça dit qui nous sommes
nous sommes alors partout on n'est pas
il y a pas que chez nous les italiens
font une cuisine extraordinaire partout
les gens aiment bien manger mais quand
même en France on a cette tradition
cette histoire de de la recherche du bon
produit de la valorisation des terroirs
de l'envie de bien manger de partager
avec les autres le repas français il
dure longtemps parce qu'on aime partager
on aime boire des coups on aime on fait
on réfléchit à la cormeving etc et je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose voilà
qu'il nous faut qu'il nous faut garder
moi je j'adore les bons produits j'adore
bien manger en revanche j'aime pas la
junkwood mais oui mais Audrey c'est le
paradoxe quand on dit une bonne viande
un bon fromage et un bon vin et on se
fait ratatiner sur les réseaux sociaux
et par la classe politique
je suis pas du tout d'accord avec Fabien
Roussel
la chose politiquement si c'est lui il
en fait un espèce de truc de les classes
populaires contre les bobos il y a plein
de gens dans les classes populaires qui
sont végétariens et encore une fois moi
je je pense que de toute façon pour nous
pour nous pour la santé humaine pour la
préservation non seulement de
l'environnement et de la BU mais de la
biodiversité il nous faut réduire nos
consommations de protéines karnées que
ce soit la viande que ce soit le poisson
parce que la ressource halieutique elle
n'est pas indéfinie mais je ne vais pas
jusqu'à dire qu'il faille tout arrêter
moi je peux faire le choix à un moment
individuellement de tout arrêter les
choses trois quarts végétariennes ça
m'arrive de passer six mois sans manger
devient ou de poisson encore une fois je
garde de bœuf
beurre et fromage mais
c'est mon choix individuel je sais qu'à
l'échelle de la population d'un pays
comme la France à l'échelle de la
population mondiale si nous voulons que
nos enfants et nos petits-enfants et
nous-mêmes parce que certains d'entre
nous vont vivre encore au moins 40 ans
vivre sur une planète qui soit habitable
qui soit vivable il nous faut réduire
nos consommations carnées alors ce que
je propose c'est qu'on mange encore une
fois moins de viande moins de poissons
mais de meilleure qualité du poisson
empêche durable de la viande produite en
France on a d'excellents producteurs de
viande en France on a d'excellents
produits voilà profitons-en avec
une mesure vous m'avez l'air de bien
vous y connaître on va voir si vous êtes
vraiment incollables c'est le quiz
alors Audrey vous qui avez été un visage
on l'a dit tout à l'heure avec Brigitte
connue de la télé et une fan de
gastronomie seriez-vous nous dire
laquelle parmi ces émissions culinaires
du petit écran n'a jamais existé à repas
de famille
B la tournée des popotes
c'est le garde-manger et des un titre
très original bon appétit bien sûr alors
bon appétit bien sûr je sais que ça
existait exactement sur gourmette TV en
2005 je dirais que repas de famille a
existé oui France 3 votre ancienne
chaîne 2010 et
alors là les deux autres je ne connais
pas mais je dirais que celles qui n'a
jamais existé c'est le garde-manger très
bien
alors là mais ça c'est le sens du titre
ça n'a rien à voir
un titre d'une émission qu'il a pas
existé ce qui est pas facile
deuxième quiz alors vous êtes né en
Martinique vous êtes évidemment fier de
votre terroir des arguments des Antilles
mais les connaissez-vous réellement ces
affirmations sont-elles vraies ou
fausses ah le Giraumont est une sorte de
potimarron oui ou faux vrai vrai c'est
bon le tasar ressemble à une sole vrai
ou faux alors le Taser c'est un poisson
blanc c'est un poisson c'est ça
l'histoire non il est pas plat donc
c'est faux d'ailleurs c'est bon c'est la
fécule extraite du tolément sert à
confectionner des desserts vrai ou faux
le tolément on le met dans les des
enfants dans les petits déjeuners est-ce
que ça peut être considéré comme un
dessert oui je dirais oui vrai elle va
tout gagner
le latoumou la poumon alors je sais ce
que c'est la toumo mais par contre je ne
sais pas si simple cousine
vrai ou faux
je dirais non je dirais faux
est un rhizome qui sert à soigner qui
est qui a des vertus médicinales du coup
on l'appelle à tout mot puisqu'il
correspond à tous les mots et ça
ressemble ça ressemble j'ai un peu bossé
le dossier ça ressemble plutôt au
gingembre
dans cette émission donc félicitations
un tout petit mot parce que d'habitude
on a du vin dans cette émission et alors
là vous nous avez demandé du jus de
goyave vous en buvez souvent fréquemment
et la goyave on en trouve évidemment
beaucoup chez vous alors déjà Brigitte
si vous voulez faire la maligne auprès
de vos amis antillais vous direz goyave
parce que goyave c'est la condensation
parisienne et française métropolitaine
on va dire donc c'est un jus de goyave
c'est un jus classique c'est comme le
jus d'orange ici ça aurait pu être du
jus de canne aussi du Cannes jus de
goyave jus de prune de citer jus de
cerise c'est un jus que j'aime
particulièrement et
comme je vous le disais en préparant
enfin avant l'émission C'est vrai que
sur la cuisine antillaise on n'a pas
l'habitude de faire des accords mains ça
existe mais c'est pas dans les habitudes
populaires voilà les gens boivent un
verre de vin de temps en temps mais on
boit beaucoup de champagne beaucoup de
champagne et les champions avec la
Guadeloupe les champions du monde par
tête de pipe à consommer du champagne
parce qu'on aime ça monsieur parce que
c'est bon parce qu'on aime ça mais c'est
vrai que du vin à table il fait chaud
en plus des gens on mange souvent des
féculents des choses qui voilà qui sont
très roboratives donc rajouter du vin
par dessus c'est assez rare donc c'est
pour ça que je vous ai proposé en
revanche si j'avais été vraiment comme
on dit chez moi natif natal j'aurais
proposé un punch oui effectivement
on partage un repas avec du ponchor
qu'en France on le boit un apéro ou
comme en plus
on le prend plutôt comme apéro mais on
peut le terminer à table pendant ce
temps apéritif avec des acrages avec des
accras avec du boudin alors on repart
enfin en France plutôt le repas occupe
une assez large place et
particulièrement en politique ce sont
souvent là que ce nous les deals
politiques que se fait la petite et la
grande Histoire et c'est la brève de
comptoir
très bon alors Audrey on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à un souvenir politique
autour d'un repas est-ce qu'il y en a un
qui vous est revenu à l'esprit
particulièrement alors j'en ai beaucoup
mais je me suis dit que j'allais vous
faire un souvenir qui lit mon ancienne
profession celle de journaliste et la
politique
c'était en 95 j'étais en Martinique
c'était le début de ma carrière du
journaliste en 1995 avec notamment la
campagne
présidentielle de Jacques Chirac et
Jacques Chirac était venu en Martinique
vous savez les candidats font toujours
un déplacement aux Antilles et donc il
était suivi par des dizaines et des
dizaines de journalistes moi je le
suivais pour ma chaîne à l'époque
j'étais Jerry donc je faisais un peu
tout à la caméra le micro etc et un
moment je voulais pouvoir arriver à
avoir au moins un question-réponse qu'on
appelle un micro-tendu et vraiment et en
exclusivité donc j'avais repéré avant
tout le monde le restaurant où il devait
se rendre c'était dans une commune qui
s'appelle faire et j'étais allé j'avais
volontairement laissé une partie du de
la fin du déplacement avant le déjeuner
j'étais allé me positionner là et
j'avais trouvé un endroit où j'étais un
angle ou une je savais qu'il allait
passer et comme c'est un angle et c'est
un escalier un peu un peu tordue il
allait passer il allait s'arrêter en
fait donc je me suis installée là j'ai
attendu tranquillement et effectivement
un moment il est monté donc j'ai tourné
en train de monter l'escalier il s'est
arrêté pas j'ai tendu le micro bon en
plus il a fait
il a fait une sortie à la Chirac c'est à
dire que il s'est quand il m'a vu il
s'est tourné vers la délégation qui
l'accompagnait
et il a dit mais comment faites-vous en
Martinique non seulement vous avez la
plus belle île mais vous avez les plus
belles femmes alors
1995 je ne suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui
ce genre de déclaration serait accepté
mais voilà
mais le compliment oui mais moi j'ai
souri mais ça a détendu l'atmosphère et
j'ai pu lui poser les questions et la
voir en plein cadre pendant 3 minutes
rien que pour moi les coulisses d'un
scooper les angles cette émission et on
va parler de l'avenir du bio quel avenir
effectivement pour le bio en panne de
demande l'offre recule alors que va-t-on
trouver dans nos assiettes demain c'est
le dessous des plats
le bio ne fait plus recette chair à
produire il ne trouve pas de débouchés
chez les consommateurs déjà confrontés
un taux d'inflation élevé sur les
produits alimentaires conséquence et
bien des agriculteurs stop leur
conversion c'est le cas Thierry qui
cultive notamment des poireaux dans le
nord de la France reportage pierre
Michael Carniel
dans le Pas-de-Calais Thierry Baillet
voulait atteindre le 100% bio en 2028
mais avec la chute des ventes et les
grandes surfaces qui réduisent leur
contrat il a décidé de suspendre pour le
moment sa conversion mais là avec la
crise concrètement on est dans une
période où on est revenu à moins 20 par
rapport aux années précédentes en termes
de
globalement sur la bio donc c'est
vraiment problématique et là pour
l'instant on est en stagnation donc
allez convertir et aller j'allais dire
repasser du temps et investir dans des
productions qui auront pas de débouchés
pour nous économiquement c'est
impossible quand on doit on doit vivre
aussi quoi car le bio coûte plus cher
depuis trois ans l'exploitant produit
des poireaux en agriculture biologique
une méthode qui lui demande plus
d'investissement mais il faut savoir
qu'il y a plus de travail quand on est
en poireau bio parce qu'ils sont plus
petits donc on en a plus à éplucher
parfois il y a un peu de maladies donc
on est plus un peu plus aussi et après
en termes de temps de travail en
désherbage comme
en entretien c'est beaucoup plus
chronophage aussi des agriculteurs qui
ralentissent leur conversion d'autres
qui renoncent complètement une situation
qui inquiète la directrice de l'Agence
Bio si demain ces agriculteurs se
déconvertissent recommence à utiliser
des pesticides de synthèse on sera tous
perdant donc c'est important qu'on
puisse garder en tête qu'il y a un enjeu
à la fois citoyen mais aussi un enjeu de
nous contribuables de maintenir ses
agriculteurs c'est nous globalement ce
qu'on remarque c'est que les
agriculteurs veulent passer en bio et
que c'est la première fois c'est plutôt
les consommateurs qui font défaut alors
historiquement c'était plutôt la
consommation qui tirait le marché bio
pour leur verre d'eau la relance du bio
ne se fera pas que dans les supermarchés
comment est-ce qu'on se débrouille pour
avoir un débouché et pour ça la
mobilisation des restaurants des
cantines de la consommation à domicile
elle doit être complète
sur la table des restaurants les
produits bio représentent encore moins
de 2%. la part du bio dans les cantines
s’élève à plus de 6%, l'objectif des 20%
de la loi egalim est encore loin d'être
atteint
[Musique]
alors le bio est en recul faute de
demande et la demande baisse c'est trop
cher vous êtes d'accord
alors c'est trop cher on sait tellement
habitué à une alimentation
finalement qu'on payait quasiment pas
que une fois que il faut payer le prix
juste tout le monde est très étonné mais
vous savez je pense que c'est une
question de volonté politique par
exemple à la ville de Paris sur la
restauration collective donc les crèches
les écoles les EHPAD les restaurants
administratifs des restaurants de d'aide
alimentaire on nous avons la
responsabilité de fournir 30 millions de
repas par an et aujourd'hui nous sommes
à 54% de bio et ou durable dans la
restauration collective parisienne alors
vous entendiez dans le reportage 2% dans
les restaurants si pour cent dans la
restauration collective une loi qui met
un objectif à 20% nous aujourd'hui on
est déjà à 54 54 avec un objectif à 75
alors un objectif
à 100% dont 75% de bio je vais juste
très très rapidement la différence entre
quand je dis bio et ou durable il y a du
bio qui est durable et il y a du qui a
notre sens n'est pas durable du bio
certes produit avec le cahier de charge
bio mais qui est produit très loin de la
France et pour moi moins souhaitable
dans la restauration collective que
durable donc on a des critères de
durabilité qui n'a pas l'agrément bio
mais qui est produit à 250 km de poids
alors c'est bio
parce que c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué parce que on peut être local
et pas du tout durable du local en
agrochimie c'est pas du tout durable nos
critères de durabilité c'est soit le le
label bio le label rouge le label pêche
durable et nous avons aussi un critère
de commerce équitable Nord et Nord-Sud
et les pratiques agricoles donc qui sont
pas toutes en bio ça peut être de la
conversion c'est au bio mais qui n'est
pas encore arrivé des pratiques
agricoles reconnues comme respectueuses
dans l'environnement qui procure un bon
revenu aux paysans donc c'est plutôt une
agriculture paysanne
et qui sont aussi bonnes pour la santé
publique et donc ça n'est pas
l'agriculture à grossière qu'il faut
subventionner cette production là en
fait aux municipalité de Paris et autres
mais c'est notre agriculteurs c'est
notre rôle de collectivité d'abord de
mettre à portée de tous avec par exemple
voilà la restauration collective mais
c'est pas le seul une alimentation de
qualité pour tous les parisiens quelle
que soit leurs revenus leur origine
sociale le lieu où ils habitent quand je
vous dis qu'on est à 54% de bio durable
c'est déjà beaucoup on s'est fixé
l'objectif de 100% d'ici la fin du
mandat c'est notre plan alimentation
durable qui a été voté je le signale à
l'unanimité des groupes de Paris des
groupes politiques représentés à Paris
au mois de juin dernier et ce plan il
fixe l'objectif de 100% de bio et ou
durable dans la restauration collective
dont donc 75% de bio mais surtout dont
50% provenant de moins de 250 km autour
d'accord on rajoute un critère de
proximité
plus cher pour la collectivité oui plus
cher pour le convive non parce que le
prix infini du plateau en restauration
collective restera le même comment on
fait les impôts je vous dis non non non
c'est pas le contraire enfin si le
contribuable paye en partie puisqu'il y
a de toute façon une subvention prévue
par la ville un budget pour la
restauration collective mais autant une
famille modeste paye son plateau repas
13 centimes d'euros une famille plus
aisée peut payer 2,50 € 7 euros donc il
y a une déjà une première compensation
le deuxième levier que nous avons c'est
le fait de passer par exemple à deux
repas totalement végétariens par semaine
d'une part c'est meilleur pour la
planète d'autre part ça
respecte un peu plus les différentes
habitudes alimentaires et surtout ça
dégage la marge manœuvre pour acheter
des produits carnés pour les trois
autres jours ou 5 par exemple dans les
EHPAD mais une de meilleure qualité
parce que nous avons dégagé de la main
pose du coup les
végétarien alors on ne les impose pas
parce qu'ils ont encore une fois le
plein a été voté par l'ensemble des
groupes politiques donc c'est une
décision politique les enfants à la
cantine il y a les enfants toujours par
semaine où il y a ni viande ni poisson
absolument mais il peut y avoir encore
une fois des œufs de du fromage etc il y
a là on a aujourd'hui dans la
restauration collective parisienne il y
a déjà un repas entièrement végétarien
par semaine l'objectif c'est qu'au 1er
septembre 2023 on passe à deux repas
végétariens par semaine et ensuite d'ici
2025 que pour les trois autres jours il
y ait une alternative végétarienne
systématiquement donc vous écartez
quasiment la viande à terme non non
vous essayez on diminue diminuer on
diminue mais ça rejoint la conversation
qu'on avait au début on diminue la part
carnée que ce soit en viande que ce soit
en poissons mais on distribue une viande
et un poisson de meilleure qualité et de
toute façon vous savez les menus ils
sont évidemment éta par des
nutritionnistes etc donc tout ça restera
équilibré ça c'est la planète que pour
le prix oui mais c'est aussi accompagner
la transition agricole du territoire
c'est faire en sorte que ce monsieur qui
malheureusement s'est déconverti trouve
des débouchés c'est à dire que nous
quand on dit qu'on veut que 50 % de nos
30 millions de repas soient fournis par
des agriculteurs des paysans des
éleveurs qui sont à moins de 250 km de
Paris ça veut dire qu'on avec le levier
de la commande publique avec l'assurance
pour ces agriculteurs d'avoir des
débouchés sur les tables parisiennes et
bien nous accompagnons pour eux la
transition vers une agriculture
biologique ou en tout cas des
agricultures durables ça c'est la partie
restauration collective et puis il y a
tout le reste d'abord il y a des gens
qui n'utilisent pas la restauration
collective et puis mais la restauration
collective c'est un repas dans la
journée ça peut être deux en EHPAD mais
pour la plupart c'est un repas dans la
journée et donc
il y a tout le reste c'est à dire faire
en sorte et ça c'est l'autre partie de
mes missions de
mailler le territoire parisien avec des
commerces alimentations durables des
alimentaires des cuisines partagées qui
soient à des prix abordables pour les
parisiennes et les Parisiens qui ont des
conditions de vie les plus modestes
parce que les autres il y a de l'offre
de toute façon et pour eux on ouvre on
soutient l'ouverture de
boutiques de commerce de producteurs par
exemple des magasins de producteurs des
coopératives des coopératives citoyennes
c'est à dire que 200 400 600 000
citoyens même d'un même arrondissement
se mettent ensemble et
déjà non non
j'en ai inauguré il n'y a pas samedi
dernier dans le 14e arrondissement à
Porte d'Orléans c'est la COP 14 ils ont
pour l'instant 200 coopérateurs et
coopératrices donc c'est des citoyens
comme vous et moi qui adhèrent à la
coopérative
vous donne deux heures de leur temps une
fois par semaine une fois toutes les
deux semaines une fois par mois s'il y a
beaucoup de monde et ça permet de comme
ça de recevoir de faire des achats de
denrées durable et de les distribuer à
des prix tout à fait abordables vous
avez un autre dispositif comme celui de
la louve dans le 18e donc là on vend
toutes sortes de produits alors ils se
sont d'abord focalisés sur le bio mais
pas que et puis vous avez aussi des
dispositifs que l'on soutient comme des
dispositifs de récupération les magasins
qui s'installent un peu partout dans
Paris qui récupèrent des denrées presque
périmés mais pas tout à fait et qu'il
est vendent à des prix tout à fait
abordables des cuisines partagées
beaucoup en soutient énormément de de
[Musique]
dispositifs d'accompagnement des
familles des foyers pour leur apprendre
à trouver les bons endroits les courses
les moins chers et après aussi les
enfants les goûts mais est-ce que le
fait d'avoir des bons produits à la
cantine ça peut pousser aussi les
enfants à dire aux parents d'acheter
peut-être des produits de meilleure
qualité complètement émission et puis
nous on a non seulement on améliore la
restauration collective mais on a on met
aussi en place une stratégie de lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire parce
que ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui
permet de dégager énormément de marge
manœuvre mais les gestes
par exemple les assiettes petites fins
moyenne fin grande faim les enfants vont
ils ont pas très faim ils disent ben moi
je fais je vais prendre une petite femme
et si ils ont encore faim à la fin de
cette peur
comme par exemple le pain que on ne va
pas mettre en libre-service en bout de
en bout de self mais on va autoriser par
exemple un morceau de pain par plateau
et si vous en voulez un deuxième c'est
possible mais il faut se relever pour
aller le chercher plutôt que d'en
prendre quatre d'un coup et dans les C3
à la fin juste une Brigitte une petite
question sur parce que vous disiez
c'était la question de Brigitte c'est un
cercle vertu on leur donne du bio à la
cantine et ils imposent le bio à leurs
visiblement ça ne marche pas est-ce
qu'au-delà du prix parce que d'abord les
les produits bio ont moins augmentés
dans la dans l'inflation que les autres
il y a pas d'intrants
du consommateur vis-à-vis du bio alors
comment il faut la régler
alors c'est vrai que les enfants peuvent
dire à leurs parents qui ils aiment
manger des produits frais et les inciter
à acheter des produits frais et
peut-être à manger moins de viande etc
mais c'est vrai que j'imagine pas les
enfants qui disent il faut acheter que
du bio parce que oui
ça coûte assez si si si on sent la
différence c'est si si mais non ce que
je veux dire c'est que les les je pense
pas qu'il y a une crise de confiance
dans le bio je pense qu'il y a une crise
de pouvoir d'achat et que beaucoup de
gens se disent de toute façon le bio
c'est plus cher
sans aller dans la boutique
d'alimentation durable qui est juste à
côté se rendre compte que finalement
c'est pas plus cher c'est même parfois
pas plus cher que sur le marché mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a cette idée
et puis nous on a aussi en tant que
collectivité un gros travail de ce qu'on
appelle l'allé vert c'est à dire que là
je vous ai parlé de la COP 14 par
exemple qui est dans qui apporte
d'Orléans je pourrais vous parler de
plein d'autres sites comme cela qui
distribue qui vendent des produits à
vraiment des prix tout à fait
compétitifs mais très souvent les
familles modestes vers lesquelles nous
nous auquel nous nous adressons se
disent non mais ça ça ne peut pas être
pour moi donc ils ne vont même pas
rentrer dans le monde donc il nous faut
nous aller vers mais ce que je voulais
dire parce que je sens que je suis trop
longue c'est vraiment que les
collectivités publiques ont un rôle très
important à jouer nous ville de Paris
avec le levier de la commande publique
nous pouvons accompagner la transition
accompagner les paysans les agriculteurs
les éleveurs nous pouvons avec la
restauration collective fournir au plus
modeste une alimentation équilibré et de
bons goût et nous pouvons avec ce
maillage de magasin d'alimentation
durable de cuisine partagée en soutenant
les amas etc mettre à disposition des
parisiens les plus modestes une
alimentation de qualité mais ce sont des
choix politiques on continue à parler du
prix des produits et de l'inflation des
produits alimentaires avec notre panier
LCP
parce qu'à fin de mieux vous informer
vous téléspectateurs sur le prix des
produits en cette période de forte
inflation nous avons créé donc un panier
LCP avec beaucoup de produits de
première nécessité comme du beurre de la
farine des pâtes mais aussi du chocolat
des yaourts des œufs ou encore du jambon
alors chaque mois Hélène Bonduelle nous
proposera un relevé des prix constaté
dans un supermarché de la région
parisienne donc elle est allée faire un
relevé il y a un mois et elle nous donne
aujourd'hui le prix de son panier un
mois plus tard il a pris 3% donc c'est
ça hausse globale qui masque des
augmentations qui sont plus importantes
et parmi les trois plus fortes hausses
de ce panier on va retrouver les pattes
à plus
16%, les œufs à plus 15% et le jus
d'orange plus 11% c'est difficile
aujourd'hui pour les français quand on
voit ces chiffres qui augmentent est-ce
que le gouvernement fait assez on voit
que la mairie de Paris essaye de d'aider
mais je regrette et je ne parle pas
seulement mon nom ou en de la ville de
Paris mais celui de toutes les villes
qui sont réunies au sein de l'organisme
France urbaine beaucoup de petites
moyennes grandes villes des communautés
d'agglomération etc qui font partie de
de ce groupe France urbaine nous avons
porté avec des associations
l'idée d'un chèque alimentaire chèque
alimentation durable il y a des chèques
énergie il y a toutes sortes de
dispositifs d'accompagnement des ménages
bon c'était d'ailleurs une des
propositions de la convention citoyenne
du climat elle n'a finalement pas été
retenue contrairement à une usine à gaz
commerciale
la solution
on a trouvé pour les chèques énergie
donc on pourrait très bien considérer
que par exemple les bénéficiaires de
minima sociaux reçoivent un chèque
alimentation durable alors il ne s'agit
pas de dire aux gens voilà ce que vous
devez manger mais on peut se dire que si
on veut
prendre l'alimentation durable
accessible à tous donner à des étudiants
ou à des bénéficiaires de minima sociaux
un chèque de 50 euros par mois qui leur
permet le bio pour le durable etc non
seulement pour eux c'est bien mais c'est
aussi parce qu'il faut contrôler aussi
des débouchés oui mais encore une fois
on arrive à le faire pour la location de
rentrée scolaire on arrive à le faire
vous vous dites c'est possible faire
pour un chèque alimentation durable mais
c'est puis c'est quand même incroyable
qu'on soit encore alors c'est pas que de
la responsabilité du gouvernement mais
qu'on soit encore comme le disait le
reportage dont vous avez parlé à
seulement 6% d'alimentation bio et
durable dans la restauration collective
une fois c'est des décisions politiques
c'est des engagements nous avons la
possibilité en tant collectivité de
vraiment d'agir et d'accompagner les
transformations de nos modes de vie
nécessaire pour faire face à l'urgence
climatique alors on va parler d'un autre
sujet qui va vous intéresser Audrey ce
sont les fermes urbaines qui fleurissent
sur les toits ou les sous-sols de Paris
qui est d'ailleurs mais peuvent-elles
vraiment nourrir les villes on en parle
et on met les pieds dans le plat
alors oui effectivement quand les
nouvelles technologies invitent dans
l'agriculture ça donne des fermes dites
verticales qui ressemblent à des usines
où les herbes aromatiques et les légumes
poussent c'est un miracle sans terre
l'une des plus grandes d'Europe se
trouve à Amsterdam ou Clément Perrot a
pu la visiter pour nous
Amsterdam l'herbe pousse souvent mieux
en intérieur
pas de méprise nous parlons de basilic
de menthe de coriandre et même de salade
tout cela est cultivé à deux pas du
centre sous ce grand parking voici l'une
des plus grandes fermes urbaines au
monde plantent Lab 15000 mètres carrés
au total répartis dans 30 pièces comme
celle-ci plongée dans une étrange
lumière violette de plantes only use
blue les plantes n'ont besoin que des
lumières rouges et bleues pour pousser
les autres couleurs sont inutiles pour
la photosynthèse après 10 ans de
recherche nous avons créé ce que nous
appelons un paradis pour les plantes
nous avons exactement de quelle quantité
de lumière une plante à besoin de quelle
quantité d'eau de quelle quantité de
nourriture elle a besoin nous faisons
pousser nos plantes 20 heures par jour
et vous ne verrez jamais un nuage ici
jamais un insecte résultat le basilic
pousse 5 à 6 fois plus vite ici que dans
une exploitation extérieure le tout sans
pesticides
entre ces murs c'est l'efficacité qui
prime pas de place pour le romantisme
agricole très largement automatisé
l'exploitation de l'emploi qu'une
trentaine de salariés dont l'activité
rappelle plus l'usine que la ferme à
l'heure où tout le monde s'installe dans
les villes c'est important d'optimiser
et de réduire les circuits de production
et donc les émissions c'est comme ça que
les gens peuvent avoir une nourriture
bon marché et de bonne qualité pour
dégager des profits ce modèle
d'agriculture a besoin de financement
solide en disant plante la-bas lever 120
millions d'euros
toutes ces machines coûtent très cher
tu ne peux rendre cela rentable que si
tu en fais un business à grande échelle
si tu ne grandis pas si tu restes petit
tu ne peux pas survivre plante Lab
compte deux autres sites aux États-Unis
et au Bahamas l'entreprise aimerait
s'étendre encore en Europe mais le coût
de l'électricité est un vrai frein
une fois prêt pour la consommation les
produits sont distribués par un
supermarché en ligne le pot de basilic
est vendu un euro 79
c'est un prix tout à fait normal c'est
même plutôt bon marché dans les
informations on peut lire que ces
produits de manière responsable que
c'est local mais n'est pas
spécifiquement indiqué que ces produits
en intérieur
ces herbes et salades sont donc
totalement banalisés aux yeux des
consommateurs hollandais plante Lab a un
temps produit également des tomates et
des concombres mais ces cultures ont été
abandonnées fautes de rentabilité
on a entendu ce reportage un profit
rentabilité efficacité optimisation
investissement
que vous êtes alors que vous voulez
qu'on revienne à l'ancienne agriculture
il y a pas un décalage je ne suis pas
macroniste mais il va falloir faire un
peu de en même temps alors déjà je
souriais beaucoup en voyant le reportage
parce que tout à l'heure on parlait de
la tradition française de l'amour des
produits des terroirs et tout les
agriculteurs
alors moi je suis allé j'ai visité cette
ferme comme beaucoup d'autres à
Amsterdam j'étais il y a pas longtemps
et déjà
c'est là qu'on voit vraiment les
différences culturelles déjà si vous
voulez vous arriver bon c'est vraiment
garder comme des secrets industriels on
ne peut prendre de photos que à un
endroit bien précis enfin ils sont hyper
parano par rapport à leurs concurrents
j'en ai visité plusieurs et tous tous
tous la première chose qui vous dise
c'est il y a pas d'ouvriers dans nos
fermes
0 ouvriers
et il sait vous dit ça un français ou
une Française ça lui fait bizarre une
agriculture sans personne effectivement
alors il y a des employés mais ce sont
des chimistes ce sont des chercheurs ce
sont des laborantins qui voilà qui font
les dosages et ils sont très fiers aussi
de dire et c'est une réalité qui sont
autosuffisants alors vous savez vous
passer devant un entrepôt vous arriverez
l'impression que c'est un immeuble de
bureau ou un entretien en pleine ville
et en fait vous poussez la porte il y a
comme ça une ferme
avec trois quatre personnes avec des
blouses blanches qui sont là en train de
programmer des robots et tout ça et on
vous explique que et ben grâce à la
programmation donc
l'arrosage se fait automatiquement tout
se fait automatiquement ces légumes là
ne voient jamais la lumière du jour on
ne voit jamais la lumière du soleil il
explique c'est le rouge
et c'est hors sol et ils sont très
contents de vous dire que il produisent
exactement le même nombre de salades le
même nombre de plis de basilic plus font
la même non mais ici le programme ils
vont ils savent qu'ils étaient
l'agriculture qui vont mesurer tant qui
vont être comme ça qui vont avoir cette
couleur là et ce sera sans salade
totalement
identiques et c'est toute l'année alors
nous ça nous fait pas rêver du tout
évidemment nous Français oui mais ça
permet de nourrir la population c'est
une partie alors déjà l'agriculture
urbaine en tout cas aujourd'hui ne nous
ne réussira jamais à
comment dire à nourrir l'ensemble d'une
population d'une ville ça c'est une moi
je suis chargée de développement de la
culture urbaine de Paris parce que Paris
n'a pas sa ferme verticale encore
on a 30 hectares d'agriculture notre
amour ce monsieur à Paris mais pour
nourrir les parisiens avec de
l'agriculture urbaine il faudrait
cultiver une fois et demi la surface de
Paris donc ça n'a pas de sens et c'est
comme ça pour toutes les villes c'est un
maillon de la chaîne et oui ça fait
partie de l'alimentation de même et ça
ne peut pas être que ça aujourd'hui
c'est quoi c'est pour faire le local
c'est une partie c'est une partie
ce genre d'installation ne fait rêver
aucun français mais il faut se dire que
ça fait partie c'est une un maillon de
la solution l'agriculture
urbaine ne va pas nourrir l'ensemble des
populations divines ni aujourd'hui ni
demain enfin sauf si on mange des
petites graines mais c'est ça peut être
un maillon de la chaîne pour par exemple
de la proximité après je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit si bon marché
Amsterdam nous on a 30 hectar
urbaine intra-muros à Paris on a de la
pleine terre de la des plantes en sacs
il y a de l'agriculture qui vient
d'agriculture urbaine
on a des bacs on a de l'hydroponie
c'est-à-dire les tours blanches là qu'on
voit qu'ils ont très futur ils sont
nadolaquaponie en fait le propre de
l'agriculture urbaine c'est qu'elle doit
s'adapter à un milieu c'est il y a pas
beaucoup d'espace il y a pas beaucoup de
fonciers donc on fait comme on veut au
niveau du goût c'est comment à Paris en
tout cas au niveau du goût on est très
bien là je n'ai pas pu goûter j'ai
visité beaucoup de fermes mais on m'a
jamais laissé goûter donc je ne sais pas
si le goût est bon mais enfin ils ont
l'air d'en être satisfait mais encore
une fois là c'est une partie de la
solution ça ne peut pas être toute la
solution et évidemment
à un moment j'avais l'impression d'être
dans un épisode de Black Mirror quand
une des personnes m'a dit ah si on va
avoir des ouvriers dans notre serre
bientôt puisqu'on va avoir des abeilles
quels seront les ce seront les seuls les
seules ouvriers c'est je ne critique pas
oui il y a un dernier point sur ce sujet
c'est que même si ça nous paraît
complètement abracadabrantesque ce sont
des entreprises qui sont profitables qui
se développent et toutes les entreprises
que j'ai vu toutes les fermes verticales
que j'ai vu à Amsterdam tous les patrons
c'était essentiellement des hommes m'ont
dit que leur ambition c'était de
conquérant conquérir le monde
dans des sous-sols ou sur des toits on a
de l'agriculture urbaine en sous-sol
aussi beaucoup de demandes
d'agriculteurs qui veulent s'installer
comme ça on a aujourd'hui à peu près 300
sites d'agriculture en benne à Paris
aussi bien vertical par exemple avec le
houblon ou avec des murs à pêche des
murs à pois on a des champignons et des
endives qui poussent en sous-sol et qui
sont très bonnes on a le vrai champignon
de Paris oui
le problème c'est que pour ce genre de
ferme le Clément Perrot le dit dans son
sujet il faut des très grandes surfaces
donc c'est pas évident d'avoir des
friches ou des par qui parce qu'il faut
du rendement il faut produire une fois
c'est pas du tout le modèle nous à Paris
vers lequel on se dirige je pense que
voilà si vous me la question est de
manière globale je pense qu'il va
falloir compter aussi avec ça et nous ce
n'est pas le modèle que nous prenons à
Paris le mètre carré est cher à Paris
donc ça arrangeait d'autant plus le prix
de l'agriculture urbaine alors puisqu'on
a fini notre notre plat qu'on a dégusté
ensemble et bien on va passer à présent
au dessert et c'est le péché mignon
Brigitte le temps du sucré avec une non
pas une friandise des îles bien qu'on
ait une petite surprise de la part de
notre restaurateur mais une religieuse
au chocolat la religieuse au chocolat
est une pâtisserie qui a été inventée
figurez-vous en 1856 chez Frascati qui
était un célèbre café parisien tenu par
un glacier napolitain la recette
d'identique à celle de l'éclair mais là
il y a deux choux superposés un gros
chou qui fait le corps de la religion et
un chou deux fois plus petit qui fait la
tête de la religieuse et pourquoi ça on
a appelé sa religieuse parce
qu'effectivement le glaçage au chocolat
ou même le glaçage à la vanille
ressemblait à la couleur de l'aube de la
religieuse et je crois que derrière il y
a encore une petite histoire de la part
d'audresser votre ADN de Proust vous
m'avez demandé un dessert qui a un sens
particulier rien à plaint j'adore
mais bon ce dessert qui n'est pas
martiniquais pas du tout je l'ai je l'ai
choisi parce que c'est mon premier
contact enfin c'est mon mon souvenir du
premier contact culinaire avec ah oui je
suis venue pour la première fois à Paris
en 1979 on était pas né en 1979 j'étais
enfant et c'était la première fois donc
je venais à Paris et j'habitais enfin
j'étais dans un appartement qui était
situé rue boucico et il y avait une
pâtisserie forcément extraordinaire mais
pour moi
7-8 ans enfin j'avais 7 ans pour moi
c'était
une pâtisserie extraordinaire parce que
je voyais des gâteaux que je n'avais
jamais vu ma vie
je savais pas ce que c'était il y avait
la religieuse au chocolat et je salivais
devant parce que je n'y ai pas eu droit
tout de suite c'était bon c'était une
fois de temps en temps
et j'étais fascinée par ces deux boules
là la petite et la grande je me disais
est-ce que je vais commencer par la
petite ce que je vais commencer par la
grande quel goussa et tout et un jour
donc j'ai enfin on m'a acheté une
religieuse au chocolat et c'était ça a
été c'était divin et donc c'est voilà
pour moi oui
tu es là pour savoir si ça vous ramène
aux années 70 voilà donc depuis je suis
passé à la religieuse au café je préfère
la religieuse au café mais c'est vrai
que voilà pour moi c'est est-ce que les
différents
on a la réponse alors voilà oui parce
que ça ressemble à l'éclair au chocolat
ça exactement
[Musique]
superposition des deux là c'était pour
moi c'était vraiment quelque chose de
faire par incapable mais peut-être c'est
des histoires de de climat aussi de
faire de la pâtisserie comme ça dans les
Antilles où on mais on a d'autres
gâteaux oui non mais pas avec de la
crème pas avec de des fonds glacés etc
pas la pâtisserie métropolitaine des
Antilles le Mont Blanc avec de la crème
de coco super bon c'est une génoise
fourrée à la crème de la crème de coco
avec du de la noix de coco râpée
tout mon Amour
très très bon gâteau le qu'est-ce qu'on
a encore le pain doux le 4K et puis on a
beaucoup de friandises aussi quelque
chose qui s'appelle le caramel pistache
alors vos députés antillais seront de
quoi je parle ça c'est dans casser
garantie parce que c'est très dur c'est
du caramel qui durcit avec avec de la
pistache les douze lettres coco les 12
lettres c'est c'est des douceurs de coco
enfin il y a plein de patates douces je
vous l'offrirai puisque c'est le
restaurateur qui qui vous fait cette
petite surprise je ne connaissais pas
fondante
sur la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro de politique à table sur SCP